some day we will hopefully find out the truth
about what afflicts Donald Trump and what
is responsible for his increasingly auratic
behavior and the speech trouble and the memory
trouble.
But for now all we have our experts who are
sounding the alarm based on his publicly available
behavior.
And we've been talking about this for years
and slowly but surely the discussion is moving
more and more to mainstream places.
We now have a series of mental health professionals
starting with a from New York city, uh, Ben
Michealas who did an analysis of Donald Trump's
vocabulary over time.
And what he found is that from, so vocabulary
has become more and more simple over time
with deteriorating sentence structure.
And numerous experts believe that this is
indeed surprise, a sign of cognitive decline
by the president of the United States.
Now, so some are arguing, well you know, he's
getting to be in his mid seventies there might
be some speech decline that would be observable
in anybody that age and that sometimes does
happen.
But again, mental health professional saying
that what Trump is experiencing, what he is
exhibiting exceeds just age related cognitive
decline.
When you look at 80 plus year old attorney
Alan Dershowitz, I don't agree with a word
the guy says lately, but you see a drastic
difference in cognitive function when compared
to Donald Trump relative to both of their
baselines.
When you go and look at five and 10 year old
videos of them, a lot of people seem to forget
that Donald Trump used to be very articulate.
The psychologist, Ben Michealas says that
some deterioration in a 73 year old would
not be hugely surprising, although not a requirement
by any means, but that what we are seeing
exceeds that John Montgomery is also a psychologist
and says that Trump must be tested so that
we can know what's going on and says quote.
I think it's pretty safe to say that Trump
has had significant cognitive decline over
the years.
Neuro psychologist, Sterling Johnson says
it could be stress-related cognitive decline.
It could be related to neuro degenerative
degenerative.
That's difficult to say.
Neuro degenerative disease or now I'm thinking
I've cognitive decline or a normal cognitive
decline that comes with aging.
We've talked about the slurring of words.
We've talked about the dilated pupils, even
in bright rooms with professional stage lighting.
We've talked about all of these instances
and this could be anything from a dementia
type decline to drug use to the side effects
of pharmaceutical medications to anything
in between.
There's also notably the difference between
the two trumps.
We've talked before about upper Trump, the
guy tweeting hundreds of times a day and re-tweeting,
speaking quickly at events with the rapid
sniffing, and then there's downer Trump tired,
slurring, low energy.
Trump very slowly reading the teleprompter.
There's the misstating people's names and
words, everything to, to from a, you know,
Tim Appel to Marilyn Lockheed to wanting the
oranges of an investigation
sacrifice every day for the furniture, the
future of their children.
I hope they now go and take a look at the
oranges or the origins of the, uh, investigation.
We appreciate it very much.
Tim Apple, Maryland, Lockheed Mike Balkan,
as you know, is in Russia.
Mike lbs justice Anthony, you know what I'm
talking about?
In June of 1775, the continental Congress
created a unified army, our army, Mandy, and
it ran the ramparts.
It took over the airports.
There's those shoulder spasms that coincide
with the mixed up or mistaken words that we've
observed.
Add shelter, criminal look, look like it.
Let me begin by wishing you a beautiful, I
look here.
Remember this, Democrats decided to, she'll
add shelter.
Grim, look, look, wait.
You have criminals, a Washington president
here in Wildwood, New Jersey.
I just want to get a quick comment before
we toss it over to Tucker.
Molly Hammond.
There's the times that his tongue seems to
sort of get in the way of his teeth.
Like in this example,
your campaign of Tara murder may hum will
not be tolerated any longer.
It will
one more example of that to show you
based on the core principles of fairness and
reciprocity, what, okay, they can name it
whatever they can name it pitches and God
bless United States.
These are episodes of some kind.
We just don't know exactly what and you know,
we need to be consistent.
Uh, we set, Bernie Sanders said he'd release
his full medical records.
I said earlier today, he should do it because
he promised to do it and we should know.
Uh, Donald Trump said he would release his
taxes and he hasn't done it.
He should do it because he said he would.
And Donald Trump should actually be examined
properly and fully for what's going on here.
There's just too many experts here.
Everything from urologists to mental health
professionals.
And everything in between saying something
is going on.
These are clear, consistent symptoms, the
cause we don't know and it needs to
be investigated.